this year its Hamburg's turn to host the
world's most powerful leaders the 19
individual nations plus the EU represent
90 percent of the world's economic might
last year the g20 summit was held in
China this year it's Germany the two-day
meeting comes with a steep price tag it
will cost the German taxpayer an
estimated 130 million euros officials
say that's money well invested the aim
of the meeting is no less than to
improve the world key themes in 2017
better health care for all more growth
and prosperity in Africa and the future
of free trade that's the official summit
agenda at least but of course the talks
behind closed doors are more important
when the world's most powerful people
discuss controversial questions in
private like the debt and refugee crisis
or the effects of brexit and Hamburg is
expected to be the backdrop for the
first handshake between US president
Trump and Russia's President Putin what
takes place outside the g20 has also
become something of an annual ritual
protests against squandering money
against war or against capitalism in
general the police are on the alert for
violence or even possible terror attacks
19,000 officers will be deployed to
ensure the g20 summit passes off safely
you
[Music]